ni creux et son mari arrivent tout droit
de la louisiane c'est la deuxième fois
qu'elle va assister à l'investiture d'un
président barack obama
à l'époque sa fille avait juste six mois
aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion de
ressortir ce petit souvenir d'il ya
douze ans pour nikki le moment
historique de mercredi ce sera aussi
l'assermentation de kamala harris qui a
étudié dans le même réseau universitaire
qu'elle comme la russe n'a jamais caché
sa fierté d'avoir étudié dans une des
études ici ue ces universités
traditionnellement noir et son
cheminement fait aujourd'hui la fierté
de celles qui sont passés aussi par la
marguerite fournier est de celles là
ou plutôt la lieutenant-colonel
margrethe fournier diplômé en sciences
infirmières de l'université round en
1979 et l'a servi 27 ans dans l'armée
américaine et a été déployée notamment
en irak et en afghanistan
aujourd'hui ni qui termine la
coordination de la rencontre de ses
anciennes étudiantes de nbc ou avant
l'investiture de mercredi les plans
d'assister en personne à la cérémonie
ont évidemment été bousculé par la
pandémie et par l'insurrection du 6
janvier
pendant ce temps marc gretzky était à
washington en 2013 pour la deuxième
investiture d'obama nous confie qu'elle
avait déjà acheté son billet d'avion
pour l'investiture de 2021
avant même l'élection mamadou kassé
hanne musicale la nouvelle ère byden et
une éventuelle future présidence haris
lui donne pleins d'espoir mais en
escrime
cet après midi ni qui va saluer margoet
avec un petit cadeau car chaque
investiture est comme un cadeau pour mes
regrets puisqu'elle est née le 20
janvier il y à 66 ans il est maintenant
temps d'aller faire un tour à washington
avant que la ville ne soit presque
complètement fermée au public pour
décourager les rassemblements en pleine
pandémie est dans un sentiment
d'insécurité depuis les émeutes d'il ya
deux semaines
ce n'est pas parce que les alentours du
capitole sont barricadés qu'il ne faut
pas célébrer entre soeur de coeur
l'avènement de joe biden et de sa vice
présidente
les attentes sont en tout cas
gigantesque joe biden a célébré cette
investiture historique
niki bar great et les autres entendent
bien le faire